love tale and the one piece have been
swallowed by a gigantic island whale one
of laboon's brothers who took a big
chunk out of jaya where there is now
this big hole that whale has been
trapped by the world government at the
bottom of the gigantic whirlpool between
the three gates of justice and the three
most guarded government facilities in
the world
what gets you to that conclusion is that
whales in one piece always always appear
whenever love tail and the one piece are
mentioned or to be more precise i
realized that whales guide luffy and the
straw hats towards the right direction
this starts as early as chapter 8 where
we see a whale fountain in orange town
just as nami acquires the map of the
grand line from buggy and then we
already have arguably the most important
scene in the entire story as we meet
laboon at the entrance offset grand line
i just love that whale it's so cute now
i personally am convinced that laboon is
the key to figuring out the true nature
of love tale first of all the whale is
once again connected to finding the
right direction to love tale because it
is here where the straw hats get the log
post from crocus who later turns out has
been a member of the roger pirates
himself who has actually been to love
tale something i still consider to be
one of the most underrated reveals in
the entire story croakus not only
explains to the crew how to navigate the
grand line properly but more importantly
is the first person to actually name
drop the final island love tale
what's up my name is manu and i can't
even begin to tell you how excited i am
about this theory today the more i
looked into it the more it blew my mind
now i highly doubt crocus reveals this
info to anyone who just tries to enter
the grand line in fact he only did so
after luffy managed to befriend laboon
and keep him from hitting his head
against the redline however if you've
watched any of my other videos you will
know that i don't believe this to be a
simple act of kindness as well i
strongly believe that crocus was placed
at the entrance of the grand line by his
former captain roger to wait for the
right person to find love tale and the
one piece and not only does luffy say
the exact same things as roger and is
incredibly kind and caring towards
laboon but he also wears the straw hat
that used to belong to roger which
immediately tells croakis that this is
the man they have been waiting for the
man that has been chosen by shanks and
that is why he tells luffy about love
tale but we're not done with labon yet
because the first thing that happens to
the straw hats when entering the grand
line is getting swallowed by this
enormous whale
it's a reference to the classic story
trope of jonah and the whale that can
for example also be found in pinocchio
who also gets swallowed by a whale and
then leaves the whale a changed person
similarly it's more than fair to say i
think that the straw hats leave laboon
changed as well now worthy of sailing
towards the final islands la boone
himself is so gigantic that as you
hopefully remember he actually has an
island inside of him from where crocus
tries to take care of him the first
island of the grand line if he wants and
so this is where the idea comes from
that the last island might be inside a
giant whale as well as far as i can tell
people have made this connection between
wales and love tale quite early but this
theory in particular stems from my
favorite japanese one-piece youtuber
yuderon whose ideas i already have
talked about in two other massive videos
according to you duran and i personally
100 believe that he is spot on with this
author of one piece writes his story
according to three core principles
symbolism two sides of the same coin and
word place the symbol here is of course
the whale that represents the journey to
love tale but what i want you to focus
on is the second concept oda likes to
take elements and concepts of before the
time skip and then re-introduces them
after the time skip in an inverted or
mirrored way which i personally find an
ingeniously smart way to structure and
connect a long format story like one
piece
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
if you want to learn more about this i
suggest you check out my other videos
with you today on this topic but here's
a quick example to illustrate my points
alabasta and dressrosa are both arcs
about a warlord that ruled from the
shadow over a country both are
manipulative run an underground
organization and have to be exposed and
defeated by luffy both times we have a
princess that tries to help her country
and a king that is unable to actually
help their people the marines are there
to interfere once with smoka and once
with fujitora but finally both realize
that luffy is actually helping the
people and much much more well the
argument here is that the first and last
island of the grand line will also
mirror each other an island inside a
giant whale not only do we know right
from the start that this is actually
physically possible but the person who
created the island actually has been to
love tale himself
[Music]
[Applause]
so to me at least it would make a ton of
sense if croak has actually got
inspiration for this from the final
island itself don't you think then
there's the name of la boone's species
he's literally called an island whale
and honestly that felt very much like in
your face writing by oda sensei once i
started to look at that scene again from
this perspective and we also know that
lagoon is still relatively young in
island whale years so there might just
very well be even larger relatives of
his out there now in general if you love
mythology and fantasy as much as i do
you will probably know that tales of
gigantus whales with islands on their
back are very common and part of
folklore all over the world so it's not
exactly mysterious where oda sensei
might have gotten the idea from i
actually have even more to say about
laboon but first let's look at all the
other whale symbolism throughout one
piece first if you look closely we have
small whales engraved in the gates of
the palace in alabaster that is tied
closely to the void century one of the
ancient weapons and is right above the
hidden poneglyph similarly there are
whales engraved on the giant golden bell
in the lost city of shandora right there
not only is the city connected to the
ancient kingdom but according to the big
theory by uderon actually was part of
the ancient kingdom on jaya itself oh
and doesn't this on top there look a lot
like a monkey with a straw hat to you
just saying then we have whitebeard ship
the mobby dick appearing at marine ford
as the emperor declares that the one
piece is real
we see wales in chapter 604 just before
crossing the red line and reaching
fishman island that is connected to
joyboy and is home to one of the ancient
weapons and by the way there are also
wales when robin deciphers the poneglyph
there
then after leaving fishman island and
entering the new world the straw hats
are welcomed by a pot of island whales
mirroring the encounter with laboon and
marking their progress towards finding
the last islands after that it takes a
while for a whale to appear again but it
finally happens on zou where there is
this giant whale shaped tree that
contains the first road poneglyph
pointing the direction to love tale
i think it's also worth mentioning at
this point that zunisha herself is
connected to the whale theory very
closely i think oda basically took the
classic idea of the whale with an island
on its back and turned that into an
elephant that is also closely connected
to the void century it proves to me that
having a giant creature that harbors an
entire island is very much possible
zunisha has been tasked with walking to
a certain location as punishment for her
sin so could she be looking for a giant
whale also i just realized that the road
poneglyph is literally inside the giant
whale again almost too obvious deroda
sensei so as you can see the whale
symbol is closely connected to anything
to do with the ancient kingdom and the
void century alabasta shandora fishman
island zou the only place left is wano
but there haven't been any whales in
wano have there well you might like this
one take a look at the kozuki crest of
course the main theme here is the crane
in the middle but what do you think
about the crossbones around it to me
they look a lot like whale fins diving
into the ocean very hard to unsee am i
right now this might just be a way for
oda to connect all these places but i
think it's actually quite possible that
the whale itself was the symbol of the
ancient kingdom i mean the chapter
itself is titled inside the whale but
let's get back to the giant whale that
holds love tail that rhymes because
there is a lot more evidence that there
is a twin whale to laboon another whale
just like him that has also eaten an
entire island well first of all the
place where lagoon was introduced is
called twin capes then we have the giant
kraken tsurume who lives at the bottom
of the ocean and who has a brother that
was held hostage by hodie and thus
forced him to comply
being held hostage by the world
government if you remember we also get
this really interesting line by the sea
kings
but the most important chapter after the
encounter with lagoon is
654 where the straw hats finally arrive
in the new worlds the chapter starts
with luffy catching a fish that is then
swallowed by another fish swallowed by
an even larger fish the chapter itself
is titled a pot of whales and on the
cover features the twins moss and kiwi
from water 7 the risky brothers as well
as lola who we now know also has a twin
sister with shifon oh and the chapter
also features an enormous whirlpool that
transports the straw hats right to a
huge pot of island wales
and this is where things really get
interesting as you can see because i
can't stop grinning like an idiot when
thinking about it in this same chapter
we get reminded that leboon is closely
tied to one of the straw hats in
particular brook the musician of the
crew who had this tear-jerking flashback
with the whale
[Applause]
now in this chapter brooke of course
mistakes one of the whales for laboon
and starts singing the song that always
made laboon happy when he heard it bing
sakin and to my absolute astonishment
now that i'm reading all of this again
the other island whales recognize this
song and actually start singing as well
which is why they start carrying the
sunnies safely to the surface
[Music]
now in case you don't know why this is
so important being sake is heavily
connected to love tale as well the song
literally ends with the phrase never
ending ever wondering how funny
traveling tale using the japanese kanji
for love and tale actually made an
entire video analyzing the song that
contains hints about the kozuki the dawn
of the world and much much more now i
personally came to the conclusion back
in that video that love tale might be
the underworld where the crew would have
to descend to but now i actually believe
that the underworld is the bottom of the
ocean davy jones locker the inside of a
giant island whale to which the crew
will have to descend the ever wandering
love tale that sounds a lot like a
moving living thing similar to zunisha
as you know from luffy ace and salvo
sake is a sign of brotherhoods so
delivering bing sake to one of laboon's
brothers might be the promise that
joyboy made to the mermaid princess and
that he could never keep there are also
other lines in that song that would fit
well to love tail being underwater for
example if you lose your nerve this
breath could be your last but if you
just hold on the morning sun will rise
holding your breath to go underwater
then there's also tsumugino satoyo
tsumogino sato is the village of
spinning i originally thought that this
refers to the kozuki spinning the
history into the poneglyphs which is
also supported by the line the birds
sing as they draw circles in the sky so
to me that was probably the kozuki crest
but if yuderon's idea is true that the
whale is trapped in a giant whirlpool
between the gates of justice the
spinning village could literally be love
tail caught in a giant whirlpool ever
moving now before i tell you another
crazy detail if you enjoy this type of
content the secret to getting more of it
every single week is subscribing to the
channel another crazy detail i found is
that there is actually a whale yokai in
japanese mythology called bakekujira a
giant living whale skeleton now being
sake ends with doesn't matter who you
are someday you'll just be bones never
ending ever wondering alpha blah blah
and we literally have brook a living
skeleton that is connected to the island
whales honestly i'm not sure if that's
the actual direction oda would want to
take this but it might be relevant as
well and so the overall idea is that a
giant whale 800 years ago bit off love
tale from jaya to protect whatever was
there but then was trapped by imu and
the world government between three gates
of justice at the bottom of the sea from
where it can now not escape which might
also be the reason why shanks and his
men all haven't eaten devil fruits so
they can go and visit after all shangs
would well know how to get to lovetale
even if he did stay behind with buggy
now as fascinating as this theory is if
you really want to blow your mind and
take it all to the next level this isn't
enough on its own there's actually an
absolutely crazy theory about the true
nature of love tale and the ancient
kingdom that has completely changed how
people see one piece forever and that's
why you really shouldn't ignore this
video because it's twice as exciting as
the whale theory and in combination with
it will make you feel like you've
figured out one piece